THEY DON'T NEED TO DO MOCK
DRAFTS, USUALLY BECAUSE
THEY'RE DRAFTING SOLO, IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHY WASTE YOUR
TIME. YOU GOT TO SEE HOW THE
BOARD FALLS OUT THIS YEAR.
THERE'S STILL DRAFTING FAIRLY
LOW AND ONE THING THAT KEVIN
KOLBERT SAID YESTERDAY CHRIS
IS THAT THE STEELERS ARE
ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO DRAFTING
A QUARTERBACK? NOW I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS. I, YOU
KNOW, IF A GUY THEY REALLY
LOVE ENDS UP FALLING INTO
THEIR LAPS. HOW DO YOU SAY?
NO TO IT. BUT YOU KNOW,
ANOTHER THINK OPRAH SAID
YESTERDAY IS KEEPING BEN
ROETHLISBERGER SET THE TONE
FOR THEIR OFFSEASON. IN OTHER
WORDS AS WE'VE SAID, THAT'S
WHAT THE MOMENT, THEY
A WALL IN ON THIS HERE. SO
WHY WOULD YOU TAKE A
QUARTERBACK? IF YOU'RE ALL IN
ON THIS YEAR THAT'S THE BIG
THING RIGHT? WITH ME. I
REALLY DO QUESTION THAT.
LISTEN, I COULD SIT HERE AND
GO THROUGH MOCK DRAFTS AND
DO THINGS AND COME UP WITH
SOME REASONABLE SCENARIOS,
RIGHT? WHERE? HEY, LET'S JUST
SAY, LET'S SAY THE PANTHERS.
DON'T TAKE A QUARTERBACK. THE
BRONCOS, DON'T TAKE A
QUARTERBACK, RIGHT? OKAY. NOW
LET'S LET'S
IT'S A 1-2-3 WAS, LET'S SEE
WHAT WE THINK. LAWRENCE, ZACH
WILSON AND LET'S GO MAC JONES
TREY LANCE GETS EATEN UP BY
THE FALCONS. WHATEVER. LIKE
WOULD JUSTIN FIELDS BALL TO?
IF HE GETS PAST THE BRONCOS
AT 9:00? WHAT HAPPENS THERE?
I MEAN WE KNOW THE PATRIOTS
MAY BE RIGHT? I DON'T KNOW. I
DON'T KNOW HOW THEY FEEL
ABOUT THAT. THERE'S THE
WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM OF
COURSE THAT COULD HAVE SOME
NEED. THERE IS WASHINGTON
GOING TO TAKE ANOTHER OHIO
STATE QUARTERBACK AFTER JUST
TAKING A FAILED, OHIO STATE
QUARTERBACK. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT EITHER, BUT ONCE
YOU GET PAST THAT LITTLE AREA,
YOU SIT THERE AND GO. WAIT
THE NEXT
I'M UP THAT LOGICALLY MAKE
SENSE IS PITTSBURGH, BUT
WHERE IT'S FUNNY MIKE AND IF
YOU'RE PITTSBURGH AT 24 AND
JUST IN, THERE ARE 24, I
BELIEVE, RIGHT? OR 25. JUSTIN
FEELING FOR IS THERE WHAT
WOULD YOU DO? BECAUSE THE
WHAT YOU JUST SAID, I WOULD
THINK THEY'RE TRYING TO GO
ALL IN ONE MORE TIME ON BIG
BEN. YOU KNOW, DO YOU TAKE
JUSTIN FIELDS THERE OR NOT? I
DON'T KNOW. THAT'LL BE A
TOUGH DECISION. YEAH, AND IF
TOUGH DECISION. YEAH. AND IF
DON'T KNOW. THAT'LL BE A
YOU DON'T TAKE IN, THAT'S A
TOUGH DECISION. YEAH. AND IF
GREAT SPOT TO TRADE OUT OF
YOU DON'T TAKE IN, THAT'S A
THAT POSITION AND THEN IF NOT
GREAT SPOT TO TRADE OUT OF
J HARRIS, IS THE TARGET OR
THAT POSITION AND THEN IF NOT
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVEN'T TAKEN
J HARRIS, IS THE TARGET OR
AS WE SAID YESTERDAY, RUNNING
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVEN'T TAKEN
BACK IN ROUND ONE. SINCE
AS WE SAID YESTERDAY, RUNNING
RICHARD MENDENHALL IN 2008,
BACK IN ROUND ONE. SINCE
THEY WENT TO THE SUPER BOWL
RICHARD MENDENHALL IN 2008,
THAT YEAR, BUT RASHARD
THEY WENT TO THE SUPER BOWL
MENDENHALL DIDN'T HAVE THE
THAT YEAR, BUT RASHARD
KIND OF IMPACT. THEY NEED
MENDENHALL DIDN'T HAVE THE
A RUNNING BACK. IF THAT'S
KIND OF IMPACT. THEY NEED
WHERE THEY GO, THERE WAS A
A RUNNING BACK. IF THAT'S
BACK-AND-FORTH YESTERDAY
WHERE THEY GO, THERE WAS A
BETWEEN COACH MIKE TOMLIN AND
BACK-AND-FORTH YESTERDAY
A REPORTER ON THE QUESTION OF
BETWEEN COACH MIKE TOMLIN AND
WHO'S IN CHARGE ON DRAFT DAY,
A REPORTER ON THE QUESTION OF
HAVE A LISTEN.
WHO'S IN CHARGE ON DRAFT DAY,
EXCLUSIVE IS THE DECISION
HAVE A LISTEN.
MAKING FROM THE PROCESS TO
EXCLUSIVE IS THE DECISION
YOU TO OR MR. ROONEY, AND IF
MAKING FROM THE PROCESS TO
YOU GUYS GO OUTSIDE THAT
YOU TO OR MR. ROONEY, AND IF
EXCLUSIVE TIVITY IN TERMS OF
YOU GUYS GO OUTSIDE THAT
MAYBE BRINGING IN A
EXCLUSIVE TIVITY IN TERMS OF
COORDINATOR OR ANYONE ELSE TO
MAYBE BRINGING IN A
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE, I
COORDINATOR OR ANYONE ELSE TO
GUESS, ADVICE ON A GUY THAT
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE, I
YOU MIGHT DO MR. ROONEY'S THE
GUESS, ADVICE ON A GUY THAT
BALLS. BUT I MEAN THAT'S THE
YOU MIGHT DO MR. ROONEY'S THE
FINAL DECISION THOUGH. I MEAN
BALLS. BUT I MEAN THAT'S THE
BETWEEN YOU GUYS, I MEAN, I
FINAL DECISION THOUGH. I MEAN
HOW DOES THAT PROCESS WORK?
BETWEEN YOU GUYS, I MEAN, I
WHEN THIS JUST SAY PLAYER A
HOW DOES THAT PROCESS WORK?
COMES UP ON THE BOARD
WHEN THIS JUST SAY PLAYER A
THURSDAY NIGHT, YOU GUYS ARE
COMES UP ON THE BOARD
GOING TO SELECT HOUSE THAT
THURSDAY NIGHT, YOU GUYS ARE
REALLY KEVIN AND I HAVE
GOING TO SELECT HOUSE THAT
WORKED SO WELL, AND SO LONG
REALLY KEVIN AND I HAVE
TOGETHER THAT WE CAN KIND OF
WORKED SO WELL, AND SO LONG
COMMUNICATE NON-VERBALLY IN
TOGETHER THAT WE CAN KIND OF
THOSE IN THOSE MOMENTS. BUT
COMMUNICATE NON-VERBALLY IN
AT THE END OF THE DAY ARE
THOSE IN THOSE MOMENTS. BUT
GROWN. HE'S THE BOSS
AT THE END OF THE DAY ARE
. TWO IMPORTANT POINTS ARE
GROWN. HE'S THE BOSS
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK WE HAVE
. TWO IMPORTANT POINTS ARE
GUEST SIMS'S MM IN
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK WE HAVE
EXCLUSIVITY OR SOMETHING
GUEST SIMS'S MM IN
LIKE THAT. I DO WHATEVER IT
EXCLUSIVITY OR SOMETHING
WAS. IT DIDN'T SOUND RIGHT TO
LIKE THAT. I DO WHATEVER IT
ME FROM THE REPORTER, NOT
WAS. IT DIDN'T SOUND RIGHT TO
FROM TOM. AND SECONDLY, HEY,
ME FROM THE REPORTER, NOT
I LIKE THE FACT THAT WE WERE
FROM TOM. AND SECONDLY, HEY,
EVOLVING TO THE
I LIKE THE FACT THAT WE WERE
WHERE IT IS GETTING OUT THAT
EVOLVING TO THE
THE OWNERS HAVE A HELL OF A
WHERE IT IS GETTING OUT THAT
LOT MORE INFLUENCE.
THE OWNERS HAVE A HELL OF A
ESPECIALLY IN ROUND ONE. THEN
LOT MORE INFLUENCE.
WE REALIZED THEY'D LIKE TO BE
ESPECIALLY IN ROUND ONE. THEN
ABLE TO STIR THE
WE REALIZED THEY'D LIKE TO BE
STEW BUT SAY I'M THAT'S NOT
ABLE TO STIR THE
MY SPOON THAT'S NOT ME. I
STEW BUT SAY I'M THAT'S NOT
DON'T MEDDLE. LOOK WHEN
MY SPOON THAT'S NOT ME. I
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MAJOR
DON'T MEDDLE. LOOK WHEN
SELECTIONS AND KEY POINTS IN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MAJOR
THE FUTURE OF A FRANCHISE AT A
SELECTIONS AND KEY POINTS IN
MINIMUM, YOU'RE MAKING SURE
THE FUTURE OF A FRANCHISE AT A
THAT WHEN YOU RUN THAT NAME,
MINIMUM, YOU'RE MAKING SURE
AT THE OWNER, THE OWNER
THAT WHEN YOU RUN THAT NAME,
DOESN'T MAKE A FACE AT A
AT THE OWNER, THE OWNER
MINIMUM, YOU'RE DOING THAT
DOESN'T MAKE A FACE AT A
AGREED AND AND ARE TRUE.
MINIMUM, YOU'RE DOING THAT
KNEES. ALWAYS BEATS ALWAYS
AGREED AND AND ARE TRUE.
BEEN INVOLVED AT THE FAMILIES,
KNEES. ALWAYS BEATS ALWAYS
OUR FAMILY BUSINESS. ALL
BEEN INVOLVED AT THE FAMILIES,
RIGHT, IF ALWAYS BEEN
OUR FAMILY BUSINESS. ALL
FAMILY BUSINESS. ALL RIGHT.
RIGHT, IF ALWAYS BEEN
IF ALWAYS BEEN INVOLVED THEY
FAMILY BUSINESS. ALL RIGHT.
ARE NOT ABSENTEE. LANDLORDS,
IF ALWAYS BEEN INVOLVED THEY
ARE THERE WITH THEIR SLEEVES
ARE NOT ABSENTEE. LANDLORDS,
ROLLED UP DOING THE WORK AND
ARE THERE WITH THEIR SLEEVES
RUNNING THE SHOW. OH, AND
ROLLED UP DOING THE WORK AND
IT'S WORKED FOR THE PAST 50
RUNNING THE SHOW. OH, AND
YEARS. SO THEY'RE GOING TO
IT'S WORKED FOR THE PAST 50
KEEP DOING IT. YEAH. THE
YEARS. SO THEY'RE GOING TO
THAT IT'S THE FAMILY BUSINESS.
KEEP DOING IT. YEAH. THE
THIS IS NOT LIKE, HEY, WE
THAT IT'S THE FAMILY BUSINESS.
JUST STOPPED IN EVERY NOW AND
THIS IS NOT LIKE, HEY, WE
THEN AND HEY, WHAT'S HOUSE?
JUST STOPPED IN EVERY NOW AND
DON'T DRAFT, GO AND
THEN AND HEY, WHAT'S HOUSE?
EVERYTHING.
DON'T DRAFT, GO AND
YOU KNOW, I WOULD THINK THE
EVERYTHING.
ROONEY FAMILY LIKE THE MATTER
YOU KNOW, I WOULD THINK THE
OF FAMILY WHO'S ALSO THE
ROONEY FAMILY LIKE THE MATTER
FAMILY BUSINESS TYPE. THEY'RE
OF FAMILY WHO'S ALSO THE
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE THERE EVERY
FAMILY BUSINESS TYPE. THEY'RE
DAY. THEY'RE ALWAYS AROUND.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE THERE EVERY
THEY KNOW WHO THE
DAY. THEY'RE ALWAYS AROUND.
CONVERSATIONS AROUND AS FAR
THEY KNOW WHO THE
AS THE GUYS THAT ARE ALREADY.
CONVERSATIONS AROUND AS FAR
HANDFUL OF GUYS THEY MIGHT
AS THE GUYS THAT ARE ALREADY.
PICK THEIR AT, PICK 20 TO 24
HANDFUL OF GUYS THEY MIGHT
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. SO
PICK THEIR AT, PICK 20 TO 24
THEY'RE VERY AWARE OF THOSE
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. SO
SITUATIONS AND I WOULD THINK
THEY'RE VERY AWARE OF THOSE
IN THOSE TYPE OF SITUATIONS
SITUATIONS AND I WOULD THINK
MIC TO YOUR POINT IS JUST
IN THOSE TYPE OF SITUATIONS
LIKE TOMLIN CALL. BERT,
MIC TO YOUR POINT IS JUST
SITTING THERE. HEY, YOU KNOW,
LIKE TOMLIN CALL. BERT,
THEY'RE SITTING THERE. HEY,
SITTING THERE. HEY, YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW, OKAY, HEY, MR.
THEY'RE SITTING THERE. HEY,
WE'RE GETTING DOWN HERE TO
YOU KNOW, OKAY, HEY, MR.
OUR PICK. WE GOT THESE TWO
WE'RE GETTING DOWN HERE TO
GUYS RIGHT HERE, WE WERE KIND
OUR PICK. WE GOT THESE TWO
OF THINKING THIS GUY BECAUSE
GUYS RIGHT HERE, WE WERE KIND
WE YOU KNOW, HE FITS WHAT WE
OF THINKING THIS GUY BECAUSE
NEED TO DO AND BLAH BLAH BLAH
WE YOU KNOW, HE FITS WHAT WE
AND THEY MAKE THEIR CASE AND
NEED TO DO AND BLAH BLAH BLAH
THEY MAKE SURE HE SIGNS OFF
AND THEY MAKE THEIR CASE AND
ON IT. AND, YOU KNOW, I'M
THEY MAKE SURE HE SIGNS OFF
SURE THERE'S TIME TO RAISE
ON IT. AND, YOU KNOW, I'M
BEEN LIKE, WELL, AND AND HE
SURE THERE'S TIME TO RAISE
MIGHT GO ANOTHER WAY BUT I
BEEN LIKE, WELL, AND AND HE
THINK THAT'S PRETTY, YOU KNOW,
MIGHT GO ANOTHER WAY BUT I
PRETTY NORMAL PROTOCOL AND
THINK THAT'S PRETTY, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE RIGHT. IT'S KIND OF
PRETTY NORMAL PROTOCOL AND
FUN THAT IT'S FINALLY GETTING
YOU'RE RIGHT. IT'S KIND OF
OUT THERE THAT THESE OWNERS
FUN THAT IT'S FINALLY GETTING
ARE DO HAVE A LITTLE MORE SAY
OUT THERE THAT THESE OWNERS
THAN WHAT WE BELIEVE.
ARE DO HAVE A LITTLE MORE SAY
AND THERE ARE SOME OWNERS
THAN WHAT WE BELIEVE.
THAT ARE A LOT MORE INVOLVED
AND THERE ARE SOME OWNERS
THAN WE REALIZE AND LOOK,
THAT ARE A LOT MORE INVOLVED
JERRY JONES MADE HIMSELF THE
THAN WE REALIZE AND LOOK,
GM BACK IN 1989 BACK BEFORE
JERRY JONES MADE HIMSELF THE
THE INTERNET BACK BEFORE TALK
GM BACK IN 1989 BACK BEFORE
RADIO IS WHAT IT IS. NOW I
THE INTERNET BACK BEFORE TALK
THINK IF AN OWNER TRIED TO DO
RADIO IS WHAT IT IS. NOW I
THAT TODAY THEY WOULD BE
THINK IF AN OWNER TRIED TO DO
SHOUTED, DOWN, VILIFIED AND
THAT TODAY THEY WOULD BE
RIDICULED, BUT I THINK THERE
SHOUTED, DOWN, VILIFIED AND
ARE PLENTY OF OWNERS WHO
RIDICULED, BUT I THINK THERE
WIELD THAT POWER QUIETLY
ARE PLENTY OF OWNERS WHO
BEHIND THE SCENES FOR A
WIELD THAT POWER QUIETLY
VARIETY OF REASONS. ONE OF MY
BEHIND THE SCENES FOR A
FAVORITE SAYINGS, THE ONLY
VARIETY OF REASONS. ONE OF MY
THING BETTER THAN BEING RICH
FAVORITE SAYINGS, THE ONLY
AND FAMOUS IS BEING RICH. THE
THING BETTER THAN BEING RICH
MORE YOU ARE IN THE FRAY, THE
AND FAMOUS IS BEING RICH. THE
AUREUS YOU BECOME THE MORE
MORE YOU ARE IN THE FRAY, THE
HATED YOU BECOME BY THE FANS?
AUREUS YOU BECOME THE MORE
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE
HATED YOU BECOME BY THE FANS?
SOMEBODY ELSE. WHO'S YOUR
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE
FALL GUY THAT YOU CAN FIRE.
SOMEBODY ELSE. WHO'S YOUR
YOU'RE MEDDLING BLOWS UP? AND
FALL GUY THAT YOU CAN FIRE.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
YOU'RE MEDDLING BLOWS UP? AND
OWNERS WHO HAVE THAT SPOON IN
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
THE STEW AND THEY THEY
OWNERS WHO HAVE THAT SPOON IN
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO SAY
THE STEW AND THEY THEY
THAT'S NOT MY SPOON AND
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO SAY
AREN'T ROONEY'S FAR CLOSER
THAT'S NOT MY SPOON AND
TO JERRY JONES THAN OTHERS.
AREN'T ROONEY'S FAR CLOSER
BUT I THINK TO SOME DEGREE,
TO JERRY JONES THAN OTHERS.
THEY ALL THEY ALL FOR,
BUT I THINK TO SOME DEGREE,
ESPECIALLY BIG-TIME PICKS,
THEY ALL THEY ALL FOR,
TOP 10, PICKS, QUARTERBACK,
ESPECIALLY BIG-TIME PICKS,
DON'T YOU? THAT'S ONE OF THE
TOP 10, PICKS, QUARTERBACK,
PRIVILEGES, OUR OWN IN THE
DON'T YOU? THAT'S ONE OF THE
TEAM AND THAT'S THE FACE OF
PRIVILEGES, OUR OWN IN THE
YOUR FRANCHISE. THAT'S,
TEAM AND THAT'S THE FACE OF
THAT'S YOUR MONEYMAKER
YOUR FRANCHISE. THAT'S,
ULTIMATELY. IT'S A BUSINESS,
THAT'S YOUR MONEYMAKER
RIGHT? THE OWNER BETTER FEEL
ULTIMATELY. IT'S A BUSINESS,
GOOD ABOUT WHO THAT BUSINESS
RIGHT? THE OWNER BETTER FEEL
IS BEING ENTRUSTED TO. YEAH,
GOOD ABOUT WHO THAT BUSINESS
THAT'S RIGHT. AND YOU KNOW
IS BEING ENTRUSTED TO. YEAH,
WHY, YOU KNOW WHY, WHY
THAT'S RIGHT. AND YOU KNOW
WOULDN'T YOU, YOU KNOW, TO
WHY, YOU KNOW WHY, WHY
OTHER SIDE OF THAT IF YOU'RE
WOULDN'T YOU, YOU KNOW, TO
THE COACH OR GM, MAKE SURE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT IF YOU'RE
THE OWNERS HAPPY WITH THE PIC
THE COACH OR GM, MAKE SURE
OR HEY WE'RE DOWN TO THE WHAT
THE OWNERS HAPPY WITH THE PIC
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THESE TWO
OR HEY WE'RE DOWN TO THE WHAT
OR THREE GUYS, THAT'S
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THESE TWO
IMPORTANT TO THEIR JOB
OR THREE GUYS, THAT'S
SECURITY AS WELL? THIS THIS
IMPORTANT TO THEIR JOB
PITTSBURGH ONE'S INTERESTING
SECURITY AS WELL? THIS THIS
BECAUSE
AGAIN, THEY'RE A TEAM THAT I
THINK WE BOTH LOOK AT AND GO
THERE KIND OF CLOTHES THEY
ARE. AND I MEAN, IT'S REALLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ROSTER,
REBUILD THE OLD LINE AND GET
A RUNNING GAME. AND THAT'S
WHERE I GO BACK TO. THIS IS
GET, I MEAN AGAIN IF THERE
WAS A QUARTERBACK ON THE
BOARD, WHAT WOULD YOU DO THIS
YEAR DOWN? YEAH. TRADE DOWN
WOULD OR WHAT IF YOU KNOW OR
WHAT. IF THERE'S THE
QUARTERBACK THERE. YEAH AND
YOU KNOW THERE'S A REALLY
GOOD OLD LINEMAN ON THE BOARD
TO THAT YOU KNOW, IS GOING TO
YOU KNOW, HELP YOUR FOOTBALL
AND HELP THAT RUNNING GAME.
AND
BEN BE, YOU KNOW, MAYBE A TOM
BRADY TYPE STORY HERE THAT'S
WHERE IT DOES GET YOU KNOW
VERY INTERESTING AND
INTRIGUING AS FAR AS THIS
DRAFTS CONCERNED WITH
PITTSBURGH DEPENDS ON THE
GAP BETWEEN THAT OL. I'M IN
THE GUY THAT I THINK I CAN
GET LOWER. YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT BIG OF A GAP TRADE DOWN
AND USE THE OTHER PICK ON
ANOTHER LAUNDRESS A LOTTERY
TICKETS. MORE GUYS, YOU CAN
COME IN AND HELP U